uh let's go next to our
caller from the 832 area code who's
calling today from 832
uh hi my name's drew can you hear me
yeah drew what's going on
oh that's not much um basically my
question is more regarding
the potential victory that we may or as
democrats we might actually have
do you think that uh if we end up
winning in 2020
like collectively i'm talking the senate
the house and the presidency
do you think we can pull the same stuff
that dick cheney pulled in 2010
and basically redistricts so that we
have more control over the legislature
and basically reverse uh
redistricting if you will okay yeah so
very important so you're
you're pointing out not only do
democrats have the opportunity to take
the white house take the senate and
maintain or extend control in the house
we also are in a sense this year
the 2020 census and in 2021
that census will be used
for a whole bunch of different things
including redistricting figuring out
distribution of funds the answer is yes
and you know this is the there's a
there's a discussion that sometimes
happens about
should the left just go low in order to
keep up with the right
and very often i believe the answer is
no
in the sense that if we need to do the
immoral things they do to win
we're not really better we're just
saying
hey we're all willing to do the same
stuff because we think we're right that
makes us just as bad as them and and so
with a lot of these things i'm not
for that when it comes to the census
um if democrats have the opportunity
in 2021 to do
all of the things that republicans did
after the 2010 census
then they there's actually a moral
imperative to do it because
this is not about changing the system
right now this is how it works and
the opportunity comes every 10 years and
very often democrats have
not been in power uh and i believe that
when it comes to redistricting and
distribution of funds on the basis of
the census yes if we
especially if we hold the white house uh
if we take the white house hold the
house and take the senate it is the
opportunity it must be done and
we've got to do it and not look back
i see that's i i like you taking the
high ground but i've got to be honest
i'm tired of taking the high ground when
it comes to republicans
i i appreciate you having me a little
bit more
uh a decent person than i am okay well
i don't know that it's that i mean i
think forever it's interesting that you
say say it that way because
i think just everybody has a different
bar you know some people would steal to
feed their family
and some people would kill one person
and some people might commit genocide to
feed their family and it's not about
good versus bad necessarily in such
moralistic terms
but i you know i i just i do think that
um
uh it's it's sometimes a difference of
circumstance as well
and uh there's there's no necessarily
right or wrong answer but i i appreciate
the topic being brought up
it is an important one
thank you very much okay thank you
appreciate the phone call